Let us say that you are miserable and miserable
Okay...
Here's a solution
Find out what's worth to you ...
And get rid of it ...
Well, we can probably say it is a relationship you are in
Maybe it is your relationship with your parents
That relationship is a satisfactory one
But you are doomed to do it
No wonder it's a relationship with your parents
You are suffering terribly because of it
What do you do?
Maybe let it go / end it is a sacrifice
The idea is that it will explain the future to you
Very often when people suffer horribly
Not always, because you sometimes only suffer
Stupidly, blindly and without shelter
You get cancer and then you die
We have no idea how to handle it
But sometimes the reason you are suffering
It is simply that you do not get rid of the thing that bites you
"I can not get rid of that," she says.
I had reviewers such as "I can not stop communicating with my mom who calls me 3 times a day"
"Every day of my life ... does not say anything other than critical and insulting words that are unbelievable"
"I can not get rid of that"
Okay...
This is not a good idea
The funny thing is often when people get rid of something like that
Go away ... Solves himself and returns to them
So they do not end up losing it even
But unless they are ready to call him, he goes on to sacrifice himself
They will not make any progress at all
So one of the rules is ...
If people are hindering your progress ...
You must sacrifice your relationship with them
It is a very very harsh base